so this is really cool i was able to
make this little store here where you
can buy my nfts and other than
programming time you don't have to
invest any actual money
nfts are kind of the rage these days but
i've pretty much avoided them or
learning literally anything about them
until now it's kind of been eternally on
my to-do list for things to learn about
and of course maybe now isn't the best
time but i decided to dig in and learn a
bit about them so what is an nft nft
stands for non-fungible token fungible
being a word i don't use very often it
means exchanging for something identical
like money is fungible people aren't
so an nft or a non-fungible token well
from what i can gather it seems to be a
record on the blockchain that points to
some metadata
in essence it's kind of like having a
row in an append only spreadsheet that
contains a url your nft is basically an
id or in my example a row index and that
url points to a piece of json data
somewhere on the internet and that's it
that seems to be all nfts are and of
course running that spreadsheet takes
the electricity of a small country but
on the other hand it's also painfully
slow to do anything so win-win now the
problem is i'm not a crypto expert
so i'm kind of grasping around in the
dark here my rough plan will be to break
this down into a few steps
number one let's get basic nft minting
going no frills or fancy thumbnails or
anything the second step i'll figure out
how to do those thumbnails and stuff and
obviously we need these to properly show
up as nfts so having it show up on say
openc with the thumbnail and description
and all that extra fancy stuff like
attributes would be great
and finally
let's make it so that buyers pay for the
minting and not me
this is called lazy minting and it's
supported on major sites like openc i'm
not quite sure how it works
so what i'm choosing to do most of the
development in is hard hat which is an
ethereum development environment the
reason i'm going with this is because i
can run it locally i can do all of my
tests quickly and easily without
bothering to deploy this to the actual
main net or even a test net so i'm going
to kind of blow through the first steps
basically they are create a directory
where we're going to do all of this
initialize node install hard hat ethers
waffles all the dependencies really
now ethers.js is a library that
interacts with ethereum it's basically
our api to talk to ethereum
and waffle is the testing framework so
that we can develop locally against our
own tests we do make dir an ft project
and cd into it we do npm init
npm install and a bunch of dependencies
of course those take a minute to install
after that we need to run npx hard hat
this pops up this menu on the command
line that helps you through the process
of creating a config file
we're just going to go with an
emptyhardhat.config.js
now there's really nothing interesting
to note in the config file at first
all it has is basically the version of
solidity that you'll be compiling
against
solidity being the language that you
write smart contracts in i've got mine
set up to the latest version of solidity
so i just went to
soliditylang.org and checked out
whatever the latest was and went with
that
so that's it and we're ready to actually
do something what you're looking at here
is the first nft contract i've created
this in contracts example dot sol
and this is like a super bare bone
simple one it's basically as simple as
you can get at the top you've got the
solidity version then you've got these
import lines i'll kind of go through
them quickly
now open zeppelin is a set of ready-made
contracts that you can build from so
it's a great starting point for building
our nft since they already have pre-made
nft support
erc 721 is the standard for representing
nfts
so this is exactly what we want to build
off of
and you've also got erc721 uri storage
which as the name implies is an
extension that allows you to save urls
with the nft
then these imports are kind of helper
thingies counter is well a counter it's
a wrapper around a number that goes up
or down by one not really important
vulnerable gives you access to some
behavior that restricts access
so nobody else can do stuff to your
contract just you
most of it is pretty uninteresting save
for the mint nft call it takes two
parameters an address of whoever is
going to own the thing and the url that
you're going to save for the nft then
internally it increments a counter calls
mint which is actually a built-in
function in erc721 contracts
and that does literally all of the work
of actually creating the nft then you
associate the url with that token and
return the token id
lastly this thing here has a modifier
only owner
which means that only the owner of this
contract is allowed to call this
function
and seriously that's it that's all you
need you have a contract you can mint
nfts but let's prove it
now the awesome thing about hard hat is
the local testing
it's not the only one that supports it i
assume other libraries do too it's just
the first one i found
and since i'm super unfamiliar with
solidity and crypto in general this
really helps
in test
nft.js i've got this file where i can
start defining my own tests so i've got
some setup code that runs before each
test this just generates a bunch of
random people basically and when i
deploy the contract the first one is
automatically the owner of the contract
so there's this
ethers.getcontract factory and that kind
of gets you an object that you can
deploy and that's how you end up with an
actual instance of your contract running
somewhere and then each of your tests
you wrap with an it call so you give it
a name followed by the function that you
want to call and then the steps of the
test itself
our first test we'll just test that
we're the owner
that's simple enough so we go it and
give it a name
let's call it deploy assigns ownership
and our test basically just calls that
the contract owner is owner.address
then on the command line we can run npx
hard hat test
and it's pretty sweet this runs and
passes and our test works
or does it who knows let's quickly break
it by adding another address from the
signers and checking if that's the owner
so
getsinus returns a bunch of addresses
the first of which is the owner of any
of the deployed contracts and then we
can check it in the test
and that definitely fails you can see in
the console output that the test has
failed so this is good
it means the test is actually doing what
it's supposed to do so let's revert
those changes since we don't need it
anymore and move on with our lives
and you can write other tests
like let's say i write a second test
just to confirm that the url that we
feed in is the same one that the
contract saves
so we go it and then mint succeeds and
uri set properly
then of course we mint an nft with some
url i don't know https foo
and then our test will be to see if
that's what gets reported back
so we'll call token uri with the token
id which in this case was 1 since we
know that the counter starts at 0
and we expect this to equal to https foo
and once that's ready we can call this
test on the command line with npx hard
hat test and it passes as it should
and if we were to say feed in the wrong
url here so https different
then when i run the tests we end up with
a failing test which confirms the tests
are working so yay
we don't really need to test this too
extensively since pretty much all of the
functionality is coming from open
zeppelin's contracts
which i'll assume work fine maybe that's
a bad assumption
so let's deploy this for real now
so i need a wallet of course and uh skip
that step
so i'm downloading the chrome meta mask
extension and walking through the
process of creating a wallet
hopefully i remember when i released the
video to edit out the secret phrase and
all of that otherwise pinky swear that
you won't take all of my money
once that's done i need to get some
actual fake money from my wallet we're
doing all of this on a test nut at first
and there's a bunch of them for ethereum
like wrinkle b and roxton
there's also some level two ones like
polygon
not really sure if this makes a
difference for our purposes but i went
with polygons since it seems to be quick
and easy and it's supported by openc
i followed the instructions on polygon
site to add their test net to my wallet
it's really straightforward and then i
went to this faucet here at
faucet.polygon.technology and dumped in
my wallet address and they sent me some
free money to test with
after a couple minutes that ethereum
appears in my wallet and we're good to
go
so i'm rich now so i need a few things i
need to set up my hard hat config file
and i need to make a deploy script
so here in the config file i'm just
adding the info for the mumbai network
which is polygon's test network
this is pretty much a straight copy
paste from the polygon docs in this line
here this is my private metamask wallet
key
you can get this super easily from
metamask by going into the account
details export private key
and of course don't share that with
people
so just a quick note this address here
the rpcmainnet.maticvigil.com
this is a public one
which can sometimes lead to errors
there's a list of substitutes here on
the polygon docs
or even better i just signed up for one
of the services listed here to get a
non-public one they're free this isn't
sponsored or anything but they're quick
and finally we make a deploy script
which if this looks familiar it's
basically a copy paste with a lot of the
setup work for the tests
the idea being that if the tests work
well then our actual nft should work too
so i run npx hard hat run dash dash
network
mumbai script deploy and unfortunately
that first attempt fails with an out of
gas error
the thing with ethereum is that you have
to pay for every single thing you do
every transaction everything and
deploying is really no exception
but how much gas are we actually using i
have no idea so i found this thing hard
hat gas reporter and installed it so npm
install hard hat gas reporter
and it runs when you run the tests so
when i run it it spits out a breakdown
of roughly on average how much gas my
functions were using
using that info i'm able to bump up the
gas limit on my call and deploy again
and this time it's successful so yay so
now we have the contract address which i
can take over to the testnet version of
openc
they have a menu here where you can
choose which testnet you're on in your
contract address
and bam
you can see that i'm listed
i've got an nft listed there but it's
pretty crappy
so let's fix that now
so openc has a metadata standard that
you can look up and this pretty much
outlines exactly how to structure your
metadata so that it shows up nicely in
openc
and it's pretty much dead simple it's a
simple dict with a bunch of fields
so i've got the description urls here's
the image so that's a link to the
thumbnail
the only trick is to figure out where to
store this blob of json text
and that's where ipfs or interplanetary
file system comes in this is basically a
peer-to-peer file hosting system so we
can shove our files in there and then
embed that url as the metadata for our
nft
and there's a js library called morales
that has a really easy api for
interacting with ipfs
it's super simple to install npm install
morales wait for that to install
and that sets up morales libraries so
that we can use it in our scripts
and i've created this new file
createnfts.js
and after that it's a few calls to
upload files to ipfs through morales
apis
i've got a couple basic setup lines here
nothing to really call out
and then on these couple lines here i'm
reading in a thumbnail i made and then
uploading it to ipfs via the save ipfs
call then i've got this second chunk of
code here this defines my metadata that
includes stuff like the thumbnail
address that we just uploaded so i've
got a bunch of test parameters in here
nothing too crazy we create a file.json
down here stringify the object and
upload it and we're all good now if we
run this new script
create nfts we end up with a couple urls
which if i go visit
those are my metadata and my thumbnails
so you can see here this is the metadata
that we wrote out it includes a url to a
thumbnail
if we load that ipfs url we get the
thumbnail so we're all good
now when i mint an nft using this
address i can go visit it on openc and
bam i have a thumbnail and everything so
pretty sweet the last problem that we're
running into is that minting costs money
gas fees on ethereum can easily run into
the hundreds or thousands of real
dollars if you wanted to mint a
collection
and ideally i want anybody buying to pay
my fees instead of me
thus giving me all profit with no
investment
the simplest way is to take away the
only owner modifier and change it for
payable
in solidity payable is a modifier that's
built in
and it flags that the function can both
send ether and receive ether otherwise
well
obviously it can't
so by simply swapping this to payable
now buyers can just call them in
function themselves but the obvious
downside is that we can't control the
price
you can see here that i can make a quick
test now so in this test i can mint an
nft as the owner that's fine but i can
also copy paste that call and change
who's connected
so let's use one of the other addresses
who isn't the owner
and gay anybody can mint just fine
the problem is well at this point it's
hard to set prices you can pretty much
only hard code them since anybody can
call this function
which means that anybody can choose
their own price which isn't going to
make me rich
so we're kind of in a bind but it turns
out that there's another one of open
zeppelin's contracts
eip 712 which is a standard for hashing
and signing structured data
and the signing part of that is the
important part
an example use here on the page you can
see that they take some data they run it
through this hash type data v4 function
and then together with the signature of
that same data
they can use another function
ecdsa.recover to recover who signed it
now here's the important part
because now once you recover who signed
it you can make sure that there's
somebody who was allowed to set the
price of the parameters
so basically the parameters have to
match the signature otherwise it's
invalid
so let's see it in action
so i've got this updated version of the
contract at the top i have a bunch of
imports which just give me access to
some of this new functionality
i have this struct here which holds some
info about the nft that's supposed to be
minted so the token id that it'll get
the price that it's being sold for the
url that's about it you can keep going i
guess maybe add an expiration date who
knows
then i've got this lazy mint function
and this has changed a bit
now you've got this parameter for the
nft data signed nft data call data nft
and then the signature
now call data is a keyword that just
mostly tells solidity that this is a
read-only parameter
so most of this code is pretty much
straight lifted from the open zeppelin
docs we hash the structure combine that
with the signature to recover who
originally signed it
and then we checked that whoever signed
it was actually allowed to sign things
so we do this owner call which checks if
the signature on this data matches the
owner of the contract
basically means did we sign off on these
specific parameters
it restricts it so that only us can be
choosing the parameters like price
then the other slight modification is
that in lazy min nft
this is a payable function now so i
could take the money that was sent and
then i can send it to the creator of the
contract which would be me of course
i've gone ahead and written a bunch of
tests for this i basically wrote one for
each check or action that the contract
could potentially take when i run them
they all passed which is kind of what
you expect since i wrote them as i wrote
this
so i checked that the owner can sign
that when a mint occurs the owner gets
paid that the non-owners cannot sign it
or that if you try and change the
parameters after you sign it the whole
thing fails
if we try to shortchange the transaction
for example or buy the same thing twice
you know all the edge cases really
and we can confirm that these tests are
working by going back and let's say i
remove the price check
and then when we run the tests well
there we go we get a failing test
or let's say i removed the signature
validation
we should in theory get several test
failures from that
which thankfully we do the test that
checks if non-owners sign and if you
change the parameters both fail
since the calls now succeed so we're all
set i deploy that using my deploy script
again and it's up and running on polygon
and we can find it using ether scan too
and now you can see here i've mocked up
a quick and dirty page of my own nfts
i've been working on a shader course for
the past few months and these are all
screenshots from projects from within
that course
if you've ever wanted to learn shader
programming from the basics to the
really advanced i recommend it since you
know i made it there's a link in the
description below now we can go ahead
and help ourselves to some nfts
i have really no idea what i'm doing
when it comes to html and css
and i've made about as little effort to
learn as is possible
so this site could look a lot better
but you can click on the nfts here and
it connects to your metamask wallet you
can confirm the transaction
and if we wait a little while well
this takes quite a while actually
sometimes it takes like 15 seconds or
longer
anyway once it's done we get a little
congrats and the nft is marked as owned
i'm just going to go ahead and buy all
of my nfts
then of course if we refresh the page
they all stay owned because i'm querying
the contract now to see which ones are
owned and which ones aren't
so these can never be bought again
and if i go to open c this is totally
there
i could turn around and list it here and
resell it and when you view the nft
look all of our stats and stuff it all
showed up
check it out they've got properties so
i've got astrology sign awesome
personality valuable
we've even got stats i didn't really put
anything inside of stats
but you've also got boosts so whatever i
put in there
description and thumbnail are all
showing up everything looks good
and yeah so that's my little 4a into the
world of nfts
interesting little trip maybe you
learned something too
all the codes up on github so until next
time cheers